l'art n'est pas à mes yeux une
réjouissance solitaire il est un moyen
d'émouvoir le plus grand nombre d'hommes
albert camus se doutait-il en écrivant
la teste que trois quarts de siècle plus
tard seymour isolerait avec toujours
autant d'acuité
c'est le propre de classiques de jeter
un regard neuf sur chaque époque alors
dans la paix ce qui est intéressant
c'est la diversité des tempéraments ceux
qui cherchent à donner un sens en se
tournant vers le ciel ceux qui ne se
font aucune illusion
la fameuse phrase que camus avait pour
résumer cette espèce de de césure qui
existe entre nous et le monde ya place à
l'attendre indifférence du monde face à
aston villa espèce de paradoxe là qui a
entre cette beauté là et là la tragédie
convie toutes et tous chez nous pour moi
c'est camus killer qui le le mieux
résumé si vous n'avez pas envie de
replonger dans cani claudia larochelle
recommande on ne monte pas refait de
laura kasischke contrat comprend
également une épidémie qui surgit comme
de nulle part comme ça qui nous effraie
le contrecarrer un peu lent qu'on a sur
l'avenir autres prescriptions le roman
policier pars vite et reviens tard de
fred vargas qui a été porté à l'écran
2007 est confrontée à une épidémie de
peste noire en france et on va se
demander comment résoudre cette affaire
parce que probablement créé cette lépi
boon il a été réactivé dans un com sa
part par des gens qui auraient été mal
intentionnés à lire pour tirer le
meilleur parti de notre isolation le
récit autobiographique dont les forêts
de sibérie
le livre de l'auteur et aventurier a lui
aussi été adapté au cinéma
je suis venu me rapprocher de ce que je
10 est-ce que la dernière forme d'
aventure possible ce ne serait pas le
confinement
une étude et l'immobilité de vienne
l'autre visage de la liberté finalement
pour prendre un peu de hauteur guide
d'un astronaute pour la vie sur terre de
chris hadfield
quand on est dans l'espace nous dit que
ça film dans son livre si on pense pas
au pire c'est le meilleur ticket vers le
trouble et c'est vraiment une espèce
d'anti guide de croissance personnelle
parce que toujours cette espèce de
sourire en coin beaucoup d'ironie
comme quoi pour traverser la crise on
gagne à lever les yeux vers un
astronaute ici nabi alexandre chartier
radio-canada monde